[Music]
hello and welcome to this nope that's
wrong that's Corrine correct oh you know
what we should make a new rule that if
you mess up the intro I get to do the
intro but that's not how it works people
be so confused oh yeah how would they
cope probably probably are listening
numbers would plummet as people would be
rocked to their cores by the fact that I
was doing the intro alright do it hello
and welcome to dear John and Hank or as
I like to call it and is actually the
name of the podcast - you're Hank and
John it's a comedy podcast about death
in which two brothers answer your
questions provide you with dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from Mars and dot da AFC Wimbledon Hank
usually in the podcast this is where I
would ask you how you're doing but
instead we are introducing a new segment
in our podcast that were both very
excited about called the elephant in the
room every week Hank and I are gonna
count to three and say what we think the
elephant in the room is here we go Hank
one two three gentleman James Patterson
the author no I said James Madison James
Madison who is an author of the
Federalist Papers last week I said it
was James Monroe and 500 that more
people wrote in about this than listen
to the podcast there was a campaign
though exactly the whole James Madison
subreddit got involved there was a there
was a change.org petition it was a
really extreme situation I am deeply
deeply sorry for saying that James
Monroe wrote some of the Federalist
Papers it is one of the most
embarrassing mistakes of my entire
career
right up there with saying that Benjamin
Harrison was not an interesting
president when we all know he was the
most interesting and important president
of all American history Hank why is
Michael Cohen the elephant in the room
this week I don't know he's unlikely
just a lot of people are talking about
him on Twitter though yeah he seems to
be he seems to be the
elephant in the Twitter room he's
definitely a highly tweeted figure at
the moment he also has a Twitter
although I mean if I were his lawyer I
would really recommend that he stop
using it it seems like it seems like
necessarily it seems like a lot of the
people involved in this don't really
love taking legal advice including the
lawyers yeah increasingly Hank I really
only have one piece of advice for the
president for his lawyer for all of our
listeners stop tweeting oh yeah I would
love to take that advice and I won't
John do we have any questions from our
listeners this week his first question
comes from Isaac writes dear John and
Hank one of my most prized possessions
is the signed by Hank periodic table
that I got as a sub-award subbable was a
company we started that was eventually
merged with patreon I'm currently having
a party and someone pointed out to me
that the table is now out of date as
many elements have since been named the
idea that you're emailing us during your
party yeah I proceeded to do with a
party no we've got a lot of emails this
week from people who are currently doing
things maybe the theme of the week
anyway the idea that my favorite wall
decoration is now inaccurate causes me
minor and persistent psychic discomfort
it can't be that persistent because
you're currently at the party where this
cut pointed out so it can't have been
going on possible solutions to this
problem include reversing the naming
decisions of the IUPAC to match my
poster I think we've hit it I think
we've found the solution if there is
I'll just write write a letter
alternately reprinting the poster or
stickers to add new and future elements
any dubious advice would be appreciated
Isaac actually Isaac
we already reprinted the poster with the
new elements we did that with Co thought
cafe we put it together we thought about
doing stickers but it turned out that it
was surprisingly weirdly hard to do
sticker replacements for it so we didn't
do that though I still like the idea of
doing a sticker pack of the elements
that they created because it's real good
so Isaac what I'm gonna do for you is
I'm gonna sign one of those I might send
it to you oh that's very nice you think
I thought you're gonna be like Isaac
what I would encourage you to do is buy
a new one
yeah now I'm gonna I put here's here's
what's gonna happen Isaac just give us
your bank account number your social
security and your mother's maiden name
and we'll make sure that everything's
taken care of
oh you'll get a poster all right Isaac
you're gonna be buying a poster for the
like every week for the rest of your
life it's just it's happened now no I'll
get in touch with you this offer does
not necessarily extend to all people who
have a poster that is incomplete because
it was correct at the time of printing
but I do feel like since there has been
this this persistent psychic discomfort
that has lasted as far as I can tell
through some period of a party I do want
to do want to reach out to Isaac and
make that right this next question is
about AFC Wimbledon John and it comes
from Ryan who asks dear Hank and John
but I've assumed mostly John I'm
currently at an AFC Wimbledon game this
is people are at things waiting outside
for the doors to open and I'm extremely
anxious I'm a twenty year old girl and
everyone here seems to be adult men it's
probably because a guy asked me a
question and when he heard my American
accent he gave me a weird but negative
look and now I feel like I should go my
question is how do you make yourself
feel comfortable at a place where you
feel you don't belong too stressed to
feel blessed
Colleen well anytime you're doing
something for the first time it's going
to be weird especially if you're
entering into a culture that you don't
necessarily know well there are a lot of
women at AFC Wimbledon games but if you
are in certain parts of the stadium it
can feel pretty male heavy and I'm sorry
that you felt anxious I hope that you
ended up going to the game anyway based
on when you sent this question I believe
that you were at the game against
Fleetwood which AFC Wimbledon lost so
I'm sorry about that but look they've
lost a lot of games this season Colleen
so I hope that's a comfort to you I in
general Hank when I am in Colleen's
situation I do exactly what Colleen did
which is I look at my phone and I try to
think of something to do with it that's
pretty much it I think that it's it's
important to recognize that
this isn't a thing that isn't real you
know obviously it only exists in our
minds it only exists in culture but
culture and our minds are very real
things and and and that in that in our
daily lives we generally end up in
places where we feel very comfortable
and that is very nice that's like a
really great position to be in and then
when you are in a place where you don't
feel like you're part of the culture and
you feel a little bit like am i
observing am i intruding do I belong
here do these people think that I'm just
watching them because I think they're
weird and how do i how do I even
interact it within this social space I
don't understand any of the norms and
that like having those experiences can
be at least a piece of information for
you to help understand when other people
are in situations like that in areas
where you are comfortable so that is the
thing that happens to a lot of people it
happens to all of us sometimes but I
think that I for one am very lucky to
not have that experience very often but
I think that a lot of people have it all
the time and I know that like there are
you know there are a lot of refugees who
live in in Missoula who have been
recently resettle dand I just think
about that all the time with those
families how they are constantly in a
situation where they don't really
understand the norms don't really
understand you know the language in a
lot of cases but but even if they do
that you know just like how does all of
this work and what am I supposed to be
doing and how do I interact with this
culture is a constant stress and so
that's weirdly your experience that AFC
Wimbledon game may give you some insight
into other people's experiences I do
hope that once you got into the game my
experience anyway is that once you get
into the game and you're sitting in the
stadium I know it was stressful walking
in my hope is that once you got into
your seat you had a really good time
despite AFC Wimbledon losing and you
were able to enjoy the really high
quality third tier English football and
that it was fun please follow up and let
me know how it went and don't go to a
game for the rest of the season because
you might be bad luck all right this
next question comes from Christina who
writes Dear John and Hank I'm a teacher
and I was ordering books from my
classroom while also pre-ordering Hanks
new book an absolutely remarkable thing
which comes out September 25th
Christina you're crushing it with your
question already one of the books of my
classroom was also a pre-order and I
noticed that it is set to be released on
the same day as Hanks book this made me
wonder is that just a strange
coincidence or is there an ideal day for
books to be released each year that
publishers shoot for also I ordered all
the books through Amazon smile with the
foundation to decrease worldsuck is my
chosen charity thank you for that
Christina who signs off para IKEA
consider our que este estado hasta
Jagger
which I'm sure is totally well
pronounced Portuguese on my part uh do
you know what that sign off means it
says right here it says stop here and
consider that you will reach this state
- so this Chapel of Bones where that
quote comes from is a chapel that is
actually made out of human bones in
Portugal our parents visited there
because of course when mom was in
Portugal she wanted to see the Chapel of
bones she's you know I come by it
honestly and the translation that my
mother gave me to this quote that has
really stuck in my head so much that it
was in the first three drafts of turtles
all the way down was here are the bones
that wait for your bones oh that's not I
mean I from that from the little bit I
know of Portuguese that's nothing like
what that says but yeah I mean I'm sure
mom yeah mom are did it up of course she
did you can't blame her who can blame
her here hello I am a bone and I await
your bone I mean I think that is such a
beautiful quote especially now that I
think that mom came up with it it's like
I love that quote these are the bones
that wait for your bones like I just I I
really did like I tried to like horn it
in to Turtles all the way down and
finally Juli was like this just has
nothing to do with the book they're
young people and they're all healthy
they're fine anyway my new book these
are the bones that wait for your bones
will be out in 2021 I like it I'm very
excited for your lovely bone book yes as
far as I know September is a
time for books to come out because it
gives them some time to be thought and
talked about before people buy each
other books for Christmas I think that's
what's up
that is correct also for some reason
there is a day of the week on which
books come out that day of the week is
Tuesday and it's very unusual for a book
not to come out on a Tuesday and so
books tend to get congregated because
they're because there are only so many
Tuesday's especially there are only so
many Tuesdays in the fall and because a
plurality of book buying happens in the
last two months of the year it makes
sense to have your book be kind of in
the cultural conversation during that
period mmm interesting I John since
you're now like a big super fancy cool
author and and you're at your big deal
and all the hungry how about what if the
next time when your book do the bones
waiting for your bones body boy it comes
out if you're gonna you say your
publisher all right now I know this is
gonna sound crazy I know this is gonna
sound weird I know this is gonna upset
you yeah but let's do how to Wednesday
ya know I did I tried that with Turtles
all the way down I said I don't want to
publish it on October 10th I think
that's a weird day I want to publish it
on October 12th on Thursday and Julie
said no and I said why not it's the
stupidest fool and she was like no
because if we say we're gonna publish on
October 12th
everybody's gonna open the boxes on
Tuesday because that's when they opened
the boxes so there you go
IIIi have tried it and I failed and I
feel like my star is not rising so I had
my shot and I and I took it and it
didn't work great
this next question comes from Diana who
writes Dear John and Hank why are bricks
stacked in walls the way they are why
are they staggered I always assumed it
was a structural thing but the walls at
my college just have bricks all lined up
so what gives we're all gonna die Anna
oh really good names % off good John it
is so much more structurally sound to
line the pricks to stagger the bricks
that's why bricks are we
staggered there's different staggering
that are sometimes used but occasionally
during like the 60s to the 80s people
were like you know it would be cool
since we don't actually need these
bricks for structural reasons we make
them all lined up alright so this is
these these bricks are not structural
bricks they are they are a facade and if
there's if they aren't then there's
something else going on because when you
line them all up like the mortar is the
only thing holding them together and
these stacks and mortar the mortar is
less sturdy than the brick so yeah it's
a it's a facade and it's just to look
good but it looks worse I don't know if
it looks worse but it does look weird so
I recently for reasons I can't even
begin to get into found myself in a
situation where I had to destroy a small
brick structure yeah that I could use
those bricks to line a path that I
cleared through my backyard because I've
been spending a lot of time outside as a
therapy strategy anyway the one thing
that I learned is that it is definitely
way better to stagger bricks like I'm
not a Mason but it's almost impossible
today I keep even like a hundred 20 year
old building it's hard to take apart
with with staggered bricks ya know I
mean it's there's a reason why bricks
bricks work and why all brick buildings
look the same ish in fact you don't even
need a mortar like for a long like if
you want your building to be up for a
long time of course you want to have
mortar and it evens things out but you
can lay bricks together and just like do
it and they will stay that way for an
awful long time
really well the I mean if you come at it
from the top and like push down from the
top
yeah but --ml that will knock the wall
down but like they they hold themselves
in place I don't know that I trust tanks
expertise on bricks but I mean what do I
know I'm somebody who thought James
Monroe wrote some of the Federalist
Papers yeah no I'm an expert on
everything John all you got to do is say
it loud enough oh man it's a really good
summary of the patriarchy this next
question comes from Natalie who asks
dear henkka John since humans can be
allergic to dogs cats horses etc can
dogs cats horses etc also be allergic to
humans
what OHS if you adopt a kitten and find
out that it's allergic to you serious
dubious advice needed here believe me
Natalie know that I mean that's that's a
Russian reversal on a level I have never
gotten my head around before I am blown
away by that
what can animals be allergic to humans
yeah they can't Jon really yeah animals
can have all of the same allergies that
that and more that people have it is
unusual for humans to be allergic to
humans though I think that that also can
happen it can be a fairly dangerous
condition but my cat is allergic to
pollen and like when the spring comes
around which is happening right now she
starts to like coughing it's sad but
yeah
very rarely dogs and cats have been
found to be allergic to human dander and
and in fact also dogs have been found to
be allergic to cat dander and cats
allergic to dog dander so yes it's a
thing that can happen it tends to happen
a lot less frequently in dogs and cats
than in humans and I think that your
your guess is as good as mine as to why
that is my guess is because humans are
just bad at being organisms
we've taken it too much into our own
hands right that's so true I was trying
to explain to Alice recently that humans
are animals and she just will not buy it
she's not having it it's the dumbest
it's the dumbest idea she's ever heard
of she's like there she's like there's
that she keeps being like you're you're
kidding you're being silly and I'm like
no we are humans are animals Alice just
stop being silly dad and I'm like no I
promise I'm not kidding humans are
animals and she's like we don't have
hair you gotta show her a hippo I'm
sorry back up how would you like a hippo
make Alice believe that humans are
animals cuz they don't have hair what
are you talking about
right but I mean it's like I don't
airless like people yeah we got that's a
great idea I'm gonna show Alice a
hippopotamus and I'm gonna say cialis
humans are clearly people here's our
recent ancestor a hippopotamus okay
maybe maybe start with the chimpanzee oh
that might be a better case to make like
Alice look at this chimpanzee do you see
any relationship between that and
yourself rather than Alice as you can
see from this hippopotamus you are
clearly an animal she I was going for
her argument that we don't have fur and
so neither do hippos
alright Hank this next question comes
from Dylan it's a somewhat serious when
he writes Dear John and Hank my
long-term girlfriend recently broke up
with me and after having something of a
nervous breakdown I found myself flying
from my small liberal arts college in
Ohio
I wonder if Dylan went too I wonder if
Dylan goes to my college to Seattle
Washington for the weekend this would
not be so weird except that I have never
been to Seattle have no friends or
family in Seattle and was not aware of
having had any particularly strong
inclination to visit Seattle before the
break-up now I found myself living in a
hostel with two very friendly Australian
snowboarders and a dog named snappy but
I still don't know why I'm here any
insight would be helpful neglected to
bring a raincoat Dylan oh gosh yeah
I I think that you may have made a may
have made a perfectly rational decision
honestly sometimes you just need to pick
up and like look at world the world from
a new play yeah and don't stay in
Seattle forever go back to college but
but yeah have a fresh perspective for a
moment yeah I think what you're trying
to do here Dylan it's called the
geographical cure and it never works but
that hasn't stopped me from trying it
over and over and over again so I think
it's great
try the geographical cure it's it's good
for you I remember after my big college
breakup Hank I drove to Baltimore and I
went to the Baltimore Museum of Art and
I stood in front of all of these
impressionist paintings at the Baltimore
Museum of Art and just wept and I'm sure
everybody thought I was so weird and
then I
got back in my car and I drove back to
college I was I was gone about a day and
a half just walking around Baltimore
feeling extremely lonely and it sort of
helped to just be in a completely new
different weird dislocated place that
somehow reflected the sense of
dislocation that I felt inside of me it
probably cost like a hundred and fifty
bucks in total but you know cheaper than
therapy yeah I I don't I don't have any
data on whether or not this actually can
help can help deal with grief but I do
see a lot of people doing it and I think
that as long as it does not become sort
of like a long-term it's like escape
like like trying to ignore the fact that
that anything ever happened and try and
reboot everything I can't it's not gonna
hurt to try and be like okay let's let's
just let's go get it let's go get a
fresh let's go hang out with a dog named
scrappier chappie or flappy whatever it
was those are all great dog names I
think we might have just discovered
Hanks secret superpower what what give
me give me 20 good dog names right now
go notebook Jennifer pants yes yes lamb
Berean love it manhole nope you there
who we got there nope okay so it turns
out it was looking really good for a
minute but it turns out Hank does not
have a secret superpower that allows him
to named off reholster
by far the worst dog damn like
everything before that Alvin is a great
dog named pants is a great dog damn you
were you're on such a roll even candle
is a great dog name because it doesn't
make any sense I love it but then
I mean you just went in the worst
possible direction oh man
it's bad very nervous John I started to
get like sweaty I got the meat sweats I
was like oh gosh be put on the spot I
don't know why what a dumb thing to get
nervous about
woof today's podcast is brought to you
by manholes manholes saving the world
from sewage one large steel cylinder at
a time more of a disc but okay good
point
it's definitely not a cylinder is an
extremely narrow yeah it's very thin
cylinder I'm standing by my ridge
you know what forget it James Monroe did
write the Federalist Papers and I'm not
backing down if I've learned anything
from this president it's to stick with
your guns you don't need to use mortar
to build a brick house it's a conspiracy
this house this this podcast is also
brought to you by very thin cylinders
the coins and and symbols I love the
idea of when you're like hey um how
would you like to pay for this with
dollar bills or with those extremely
thin cylinders what are they called what
I think oh man
and of course today's podcast is also
brought to you by the IUPAC the IUPAC
it's time to re rename those elements or
just no we don't want him at a holiday
bar we get we printed a periodic table
so many times you can't just throw new
elements at us and finally this podcast
is brought to you by nervously looking
at your phone when if you're in a
situation where you do not feel
comfortable thank goodness that we have
that now instead of like smoking a
cigarette or just staring blankly at the
sky like we used to have to we also have
a project for awesome donor Sarah from
st. Cloud Minnesota who wanted us to
read this message to Jeanette Jeanette
I'm so happy you've become a nerdfighter
and I could share my excitement for all
things nerdfighter with you I didn't get
to choose you being my sister but you're
my best friend and I would
choose you to be my sister every day oh
my god I'm gonna cry
I even forgive you for screaming and
nearly giving me a heart attack when we
saw the turtles all the way down tour
bus in st. Paul which John keine nose is
not Minneapolis dftba
yes sir if I've learned anything in the
last six months it's that st. Paul is
not Minneapolis and James Monroe did not
write any Federalist Papers Oh God I'm
glad your word and stuff John just
moving through the world making sure you
know things about things oh man I mean I
you just you love that moment at the
beginning of an event in a room full of
people where you can say like hello
Minneapolis and it's just met by
absolute silence because people from st.
Paul Minnesota are extremely polite and
then a pause and then one person saying
st. Paul this next question comes from
Kenya who asks dear Hank and John if I
fill a pool with water how long would it
take for the pool to be made entirely of
new water molecules assuming that I am
adding new water when the pool gets low
from evaporation I asked my boyfriend
and he told me that this wouldn't ever
happen or be measurable because of the
rate at which water molecules move but I
don't like that answer please help Kenya
I like it I like when you don't like an
answer you're just like I'm gonna appeal
to a higher authority these podcast guys
right who are experts in water
evaporation so it's a smart podcast to
reach out to too you don't want to go to
your local water evaporation podcast you
need to go to something broader yeah
my assumption Hank is that and correct
me if I'm wrong is that if you're
filling the I would say never it
definitely is not never so in the long
term if you're filling from up like just
eventually what will happen and I'm
talking about you know on geological
scales here is that okay as the water
evaporates it will leave behind minerals
like all the ions and stuff that are
dissolved in the water it's gonna leave
that behind it's gonna start coating the
side of the pool until finally
eventually your long dead by this point
but the pool is just full of salts of
just like magnesium and
or ID and sodium chloride and all of all
this stuff so yeah you're gonna you're
gonna end up with that with that you're
just a pool full of like chalky powders
Chris crystalline something's but before
that happens before significantly before
that happens the last molecule that was
originally in the pool will evaporate
and that is a thing that you can only
determine statistically and you will
never actually know when that happens
also this would be this would change
dramatically based on where the swimming
pool is what the temperature is what the
ambient humidity is so if you like
obviously if it's like a pool in Arizona
where it's very dry and hot it would
happen much faster than if it was in
like Seattle where it's cold and wet so
yeah that is the answer to your question
we don't know but eventually there would
be no original water molecules left and
eventually it would be so full of ionic
salts that you wouldn't be able to put
any new water in Wow that's kind of
mind-blowing speaking of that Hank have
you ever been to the Bonneville Salt
Flats in northwestern Utah no it is a
subject of the next episode of my
podcast the Anthropocene reviewed and I
was there a couple weeks ago and it is
astonishing it's otherworldly part of
the big scene on the white planet in the
last Jedi who was filmed there and you
can really feel it it looks and feels
nothing like earth to me it was so
surreal to be surrounded by that much
salty ground that was once 500 feet
under salty water weird and cool I would
love yeah I would love to check it's
worth the trip plus nearby is West
Wendover Nevada which has a number of
excellent casinos uh well you know me I
hate that a lot look I know it's so I
really wish that that we could share the
incredible pleasure of three-card poker
at a casino but we're just never going
to be able to know it will be you
enjoying yourself and me feeling as if
my very the structure of my identity is
being torn apart tiny piece by tiny pea
like every card that
down is just another piece of just
straight anxiety trigger I went to a
casino with Hank once in Las Vegas and
he played a game called casino war that
might have the worst odds of any table
game yeah it's basically you draw a card
and the dealer draws a card and
whoever's card is higher wins the money
except like there's a lot of ways that
the dealer is advantaged but Hank won on
his only bet and then he looked at me
and he was like I think that's I'm good
that's how I feel about like in general
I feel like the point of casinos is not
to win money but to win at all and so if
I'm up I'm like why would I keep doing
this I beat the casino I made 50 cents
yeah I mean that is that is not my
worldview it's just oh god I do not like
gambling I mean I think the mayor of
West Wendover Nevada came up to me at
the end of my stay and said sir you're
welcome here anytime
Oh God not really but it was like that
he could have Oh God
this next question comes from Easton who
asks dear Hank and John I have a problem
until recently I thought I had a normal
name problem is I realized that my name
is cursed about a month ago I was
writing my name and it seemed strange as
I looked at it in detail my full name is
Easton Gunnar Lane but when you say it
it sounds like I'm telling somebody
directions like go east on gunner Lane
all of my friends have now realized this
and can't stop nagging me about it how
should I deal with it should I embrace
it and be proud of it or change it like
the m-mama situation dubious advices
dubious advice is requested as always I
was almost named Weston Easton Wow
it would have also been exactly the same
problem I just don't think Easton sounds
like east on no yeah I think that uh I
think this is fine I actually had a
friend who was in a very similar
situation who has raised her whole life
had no idea that her name was a mandolin
like a mandolin the instru
and she let sound this out in high
school
somebody was like oh like that's clever
and she was went to her parents and she
was like did you know this on purpose
and they were like yeah and she did she
went through 16 years of her life not
knowing that they did do it on purpose
yeah they did it on purpose I don't
think that Easton's parents necessarily
did know I stand in this situation I
would just say to my friends like I'm
sorry but my name doesn't sound anything
like east on gunner Lane my name is
Easton Lane and yeah just let it go
definitely do not change your name love
your name I love having a name it's a
little bit different and even if it is a
little bit of a pun that's okay
the it's it's okay for a year your name
to also have this alternate identity as
a as a fun little dad joke yeah Andy
Stern it's so nice to have a Google name
you know that only belongs to you the
way that Hank green does and John Green
doesn't yeah yeah poor John Green my
parents really figured out that that was
that was the wrong call well they
couldn't have foreseen Google of course
to be fair to them
if only they had foreseen Google given
you a more google-able name and also
invested a thousand dollars from the
company in the first year that would
have that would have all been good for
us ya know then we would have been lucky
yeah but as it is Hank oh how we've
suffered we're in no position to
complain oh yeah all right Hank let's
answer one more question before we get
to the all-important news from Mars and
incredible shocking overwhelming
tear-jerking news from AFC wimbledon a
question comes from Jamie who writes
Dear John and Hank occasionally on the
pod John will say something extremely
bleak like that he has abandoned
optimism and though it sounds earnest
and sad and serious to me Hank will be
laughing the whole time I don't
generally have problems interpreting
tones so what's going on here is it an
impossibly dry joke is Hank laughing at
Jon's pain does Hank left to stave on a
sting of nihilism I have an anguish over
this JV I have last one the last one I
am laughing as partially a defense
mechanism and partially because I want
it to sound like Jon's making a joke
because I don't want people to to be
sucked into his hole of nihilism I want
to have there be laughter the soundtrack
of
laughter to make it seem as as if it
isn't all terrible and and you should
and the abandonment of ominous optimism
is in fact just a little joke John's
making when in fact I don't think it is
on some of it is an extremely dry joke
because I really do believe as one of my
core like really my only core belief the
only thing that I'm I think I'm sure of
is that hope is correct and that hope is
true and that hope is the way to
approach consciousness and life and
everything else and so I am on some
level kidding whenever I say like oh I'm
abandoning optimism because of this or
that that said like it is true that I'm
always and I think lots of feel like
like lots of people I am always battling
against nihilism I'm always trying to
lean against it I always feel it closing
in on me and so I think part of why
handclaps honestly is that he's been
hearing me say this and struggle with it
since he was like three I should write
some short stories about about young
John Doe please God don't please don't
that would vote I mean if you want to
really mess up our relationship that
would be a great way to do it okay I'll
think about it
Hank what's the news from Mars or should
we get straight to the incredible news
from AFC Wimbledon let's do the news
from Mars first since it's less exciting
maybe so SpaceX is working on its
gigantic rocket the bf R stands for a
big big Falcon rocket probably might
stand for something on who you ask and
the big Falcon is going to be capable of
getting to Mars it's going to be one of
the biggest Rockets ever developed it is
a massive cool thing and they have
figured out probably where they're gonna
be making it so you need a lot of space
to make a big rocket but you also need
to be able to move it to where it's
gonna end up being so sometimes that
means you assemble it like very close by
and then you and then you you you
basically have a vehicle
that it's only job is to move this one
rocket and then sometimes it means that
you want to make it somewhere where
there's easy access to a port where you
can put it on a boat and you can take it
anywhere base it like in any any of a
number of places and that is the way
that that SpaceX wants to do it so that
they can launch from multiple locations
potentially you know like in the SpaceX
it's like long-term vision from dozens
of places all over the world they want
to be manufacturing this thing at the
Port of Los Angeles which is kind of a
nuts decision to me because and of
course lots of decisions that SpaceX has
made have seemed nuts to me but turned
out to be good decisions but because it
takes a lot of space to make a rocket a
big rocket and usually you would want to
do that where land is cheap and the port
of LA is not a place where land is cheap
so they're going to be leasing land at
the port assembling the rocket there and
of course that's nice for the employees
who can then live in a city instead of
in the middle of nowhere but you know
mayor Garcetti just announced that this
was happening in his State of the City
speech that they're leasing part of the
port of LA to SpaceX to to assemble the
bfr and that'll mean maybe faster
production faster moving the rocket from
the place where it gets made to the
place where it's going to launch from
and that's exciting and you know III
think the kind of aggressive decision
that the person who wants to get to Mars
before 2028 would make it does it feel
to you like there is any real
possibility that this bfr will be
sending anything to Mars before 2028
yeah no actually it seems very likely to
me that either the bfr or a Falcon Heavy
will be taking a payload to Mars before
2028 that payload will not include
humans but we got we got to cross our
fingers that Elon is doing is doing his
thing and and Boeing is doing its thing
and all and NASA's doing its thing but
you know you know how it is I know
Podcast is gonna be called in 2028
that's what I know the news from AFC
Wimbledon Hank oh my gosh
so as we're recording this it's three
days after AFC Wimbledon's game against
Walsall it was a game it wasn't a game
that Wimbledon had to win exactly but it
was a game that if Wimbledon didn't win
it became became difficult to see how we
were not gonna get relegated it would
have put a lot of pressure on us and at
halftime we were down to nil and I will
remind you that Wimbledon has not come
from behind this season pull out hard
stop so it looked very bad at halftime I
stopped watching the broadcast on my I
follow F and started listening to radio
w do n because I literally could no
longer bear to look directly at the
thing and what happened in the second
half is that Lyle Tay would won a
penalty and then kick the penalty which
was saved but Jo Piggott managed to get
the ball in the back of the net on the
rebound and then it was to one and then
Lyle taylor scored a fantastic half
volley off of a very long kick from our
goalkeeper george long and then it was
to two and this is a critical moment
hank it's 2-2 in this game wimbledon
have just come from behind from to kneel
down to tie the game 2-2 and they're
celebrating all the players are
celebrating except for captain Barry
fuller you can go and watch the
highlights on YouTube and see what I'm
talking about the captain of the club
Barry fuller while everyone else is
celebrating he picks up the ball and
starts running back to the center of the
pitch as if to say like that's great
that we came from to kneel down to tie -
- but what we need to do is win this
game and it looked like Wimbledon
weren't gonna win and then in the 95th
minute in the last minute of stoppage
time Lyle Taylor was taken down in the
box by a Walsall player that meant that
there was a penalty kick Dean parrot who
was injured for much of the season
stepped up to take the penalty kick
absolutely snookered the ball into the
top left corner it was a
heck of a penalty I mean Cristiano
Ronaldo
doesn't kick penalties that well under a
huge amount of pressure last kick of the
game AFC Wimbledon come from to kneel
down to win 3-2 and that takes them from
46 points to 49 points three points away
from what has every year for the last 20
years been enough points to stay in
Ligue 1 unfortunately because of the how
tight the table is it's possible that
this year 52 points won't be enough so
AFC Wimbledon have four games left in
their season they need to win at least
one of those games or get three draws
probably to stay up but they may need
even more than that so huge end of the
season coming up but that win against
Walsall I mean it really if if we stay
up this season we're gonna look back at
that moment as the moment that made it
possible I I wept I was I could not
control my emotions after after that
comeback it's just been it's been such a
difficult season and you know we've been
down in those relegation spots or near
them for almost the entire season and to
get that win when it was most critical
it just Oh felt amazing yay well that's
great news and I'm very I'm I'm very
excited for you guys to stay up in Ligue
1 I hope that that happens is that the
kind of thing that if it happens it'll
be easier next year is it easier second
year than first year oh it'll be the
third year next year if we stay up well
I know it doesn't yeah yeah with the the
playoff final was two years ago it I
agree it's gone so fast Hank I feel the
same way
but yeah it'll be our third season in
Ligue 1 it it doesn't get easier is
short answer people will continue to do
our best hopefully there will be a
little bit more resources that we had a
nice third round FA Cup tie at at
Wembley against Tottenham which
hopefully you know will will will be
enough of a payday that there's gonna be
a little bit more money in the budget
next season but there's already a lot
pretty it's pretty clear that Lisle
Taylor is going to move to a team in the
second tier of English
next season and that I mean where do the
goals come from yeah because they've all
come from Lyle
so of course you can't you can't tell
the player you know not to not to move
up a league when he has the opportunity
to do so yeah so I if I mean what what
while Taylor said last week really stuck
with me he said I we this team isn't
gonna go down not on my watch and he
clearly understands that you know his
his Wimbledon time is coming to an end
but he wants to make sure that Wimbledon
doesn't go down on his watch and I I
really appreciate that so it's exciting
it's terrifying I have to say Hank I
really appreciated your tweets the fact
that you you've been following the the
last few games of the season has meant a
lot to me and and I know lots of people
out there in nerdfighteria are following
along too so thank you and hopefully
hopefully we're gonna scrape out enough
points to stay in Ligue 1 alright John
it is time I think to determine if we
can determine each other's phrases of
the week great I didn't use mine oh but
I used it last week so and talked about
it extensively and so you should totally
be able to get it is it the DC universe
nope it's not the DC character universe
it was the bee's knees Oh weird okay
okay it was though I'm sorry I forgot to
use it I am so bad at the phrase that we
have used we assigned her halfway
through I want to apologize to all my
friends and family and also to James
Monroe and James Madison giant you just
talked about the freaking bee's knees of
penalty kicks you could have said it I
know I just got so caught up in talking
about the game anyway I want to say
thank you to Christina Menezes for
giving me that phrase of the week that I
used last week but failed to use this
week Hank I have no idea what your
phrase is oh god John you're so bad at
this you didn't even pay attention okay
Hank it took me a second but I do
definitely have a guess okay I think it
is one of the pet names that you
suggested and I
it is manhole no no but you're very nice
you're very close it was in that section
of the podcast after I had to list all
of the all of the pets people will have
identified this because it's a
ridiculous phrase but that was extremely
hard to incorporate I said that I got
sweaty and I referred to that as the
meat sweats it's funny because when you
said that I thought I've never heard
Hank say the meat sweats before but I
totally know what he's talking about
so yeah whatever I don't I I let that
slide by let me submit by the way that
it is far we're dead you thought that an
acceptable pet name was man oh look at
it is that you said the meat sweats yeah
no I think that I think that was a
really good guest job and thank you to
Brian Thompson for submitting the meat
sweats I'm so glad that I was able to
slip it in your a great work Brian and
great work Hank thank you for potting
with me Hank thanks to everybody for
listening we're off to record our hit
podcast on patreon this week in Ryan's
which you can get at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John but don't worry you
can donate without getting our terrible
this weekend Ryan's podcast as well this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
insured and gibson our head of community
and communications is victoria Bongiorno
the music that you're hearing right now
and the begin of the podcast is by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]